SPEAKER: Shhh.
Welcome to release eight
of Google Play services.
Look at this little
fellow resting
and getting ready for that
big event later this fall.
In this video, we'll
tell you everything
you need to do in
Google Play services
to be ready for that event.
We'll also have some
other big announcements.
And we'll have some fun as well.
So see you in the studio.
You're so cute.
Welcome to release eight
of Google Play services.
You are here because you
want to build better apps.
And that's exactly
what you will do when
you use Google Play services.
Let's look at the
highlights of this release
starting it off with--
[HORNS BLOWING]
That's right.
We've got a new API.
Let's welcome the Play
Games Player Stats
API with a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
Data, data, data.
We all love data.
It helps us understand the world
and make informed decisions.
And you, game developers,
data gives you insight
into what your
players are doing.
But wouldn't it be nice to
take action on those insights
right there in your game?
That's what the Player
Stats API is all about.
Because the Player Stats
API will automatically
categorize your players
according to three segments--
how much they spend in your
game, their engagement,
and their progression
in their game.
This allows you to
take real time action
when it matters the most.
For example, you can give
gifts and free upgrades
to the players that spend
the most money in your game.
And for highly
engaged players, you
could give them
stuff as a reward
for recruiting new players.
And for players that get stuck
and can't make any progress,
you should really give them
a hand and provide a hint.
So start turning all
of this information
that it gives you to actions.
Because this is not
only valuable to you
as the developers, it's also a
great thing for your players.
And now over to the
Nearby Messaging API
that was introduced
in the last release.
You know the one that
allows nearby devices
to exchange messages.
And it's also used by beacons
to send the information
to nearby devices.
And that can use Wi-Fi
or Bluetooth signals
to connect and exchange data.
But even cooler than that,
since it's also using the device
speakers to transmit
high frequency sounds,
sounds we humans cannot hear,
you know the sounds used
for navigation and
communication by bats.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Yeah, that's how cool the
Nearby Messaging API is.
And in this release,
we've made it
even cooler by allowing
your app to be notified
about important events.
For example, the Nearby
Messages API uses the publish
and subscribe architecture.
And now you can be notified if
a publication or subscription
times out.
And you can also get
notified if Nearby is enabled
or disabled for your app.
So great new features for you
to use with the Nearby Messaging
API.
And remember the newly
launched App Invites API?
You know the one that allows
your users to invite and engage
their friends to
also use your app?
Well, in this release, it's
now possible to put a custom
image on the invite so it looks
more relevant and engaging.
And now, back to
where we started.
Let's talk about
Android Marshmallow.
As you may know,
Marshmallow introduces
a dynamic permissions
model where
the app asks the
user for permission
to do something the first
time it requires it.
So as a developer, you
need to request permissions
before your code calls
anything that uses them.
So it's extra important to
catch connection failures
and initiate a
resolution for failures.
Should the user
revoke permissions
from Google Play services,
then the resolution user flow
could fix this.
Be sure to check out
the samples for details.
And that's it.
For the M stuff.
These are really, really good.
ROBOT: Do you know how
much sugar those contain?
SPEAKER: No.
60%!
Good golly!
Sugar rush.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BOING]
[SWOOSH]
And that's it for this release
of Google Play services.
But be sure to check out
these resources as well.
Now it's your turn
to build better apps
using Google Play services.
So go out there and
create some great apps.
And don't forget to
tell us all about it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]